I'm going to go here
and you feel the yong space.
So, tension dog.
You'll feel the long space. Okay. Try
it. I move again.
I do the prescribed grab and I spinal
penetrate.
You feel the y. You see?
I don't go like this.
Do you see that?
>> When he hits the yaw, I don't go like
that.
I just do my job.
He feels the yong. That's what we want
to feel. Okay. All right.
Why wouldn't this be
a yong yong class if I am just trying to
take him back the way he's coming in?
You get it? Now, if you watch if you
watch my technique, I'll do two
versions. I'll do what we were saying
and then you'll watch my technique. So,
version A,
version B.
Uh
uh what's different?
One's a projection at that point and one
is trying to
>> more details than that.
>> What's different?
>> Okay. My stance didn't get compromised.
I would say
>> what's the tension level difference
to
>> So watch watch my hand.
You see
>> watch the other one.
You can see your tension all going
through here. Okay.
So yes, I'm internalizing it, but it
that concentrically is still not
reconciling it. Okay, so remember I said
energetically form does not matter, but
marginally form does matter. Okay, so
what I'm going to do here is as he's
coming in to touch, I move it move him
sideways. So he's going to come in
>> and I move it sideways.
I let him hit the arm, but I'm moving
just a little bit off that straight 180.
>> Okay. And watch where my steps are now.
No,
[Music]
>> sideways.
You see how I'm doing that? Okay, try. I
didn't throw. I just reconciled that
first young clash. He if you fall, you
fall. But I'm not trying to throw him.
Okay.
Do a slower mechanics. Andrew,
that's where we're at. Right.
>> Right.
>> He's pushing forward. You see?
So he will gradually increase that
pressure till he's full in spinal
displacement.
This is no different than anything we're
doing. If I feel as soon as I feel the
pressure, I start reconciling the
pressure. You got it? So we slowing
everything down. He's going to do it
gradually.
There it is.
Okay. My foot maneuvers. I don't care
how you start, but we have to go 90° to
the
to the angle of attack.
Okay. Try it. Okay. Arm a little behind
you. Okay. So, he goes about a little
late.
I don't use the arms. We don't need it.
It's not the throw is not in the arm.
Okay,
>> let me get in position. There's no force
right now.
>> He starts to go forward. That's when I
turn. Okay, watch what I do though. I'm
not going to He comes in. I'm not going
like this.
>> I'm doing a triangle back in.
[Applause]
out in.
>> Okay, try it.
>> Don't I I I know I know his body is
going like this. Goes like that and goes
like that. I know that. But my arm
doesn't do that.
You get it? My arm is here. I do that.
You see that? So my arm is here. He
presses.
You see the arm doesn't move. The arm
doesn't curl.
Okay. Try it.
Okay.
Here's the hook. You see the hook? Okay.
Here you have your long arm, but you do
your long arm straight ahead. You see
that? It's hooking it.
So when he starts to push and I hook,
watch where his center goes. Plot his
center in a vertical plane. You
understand?
>> There's the hook. He starts to go.
Came this way.
Where'd it go?
>> It went forward. You see that?
>> Do you guys see that? Okay. So that
means his center of gravity is being
deconstructed
from his head. On the other one,
I'm pulling his center of gravity this
way. On this one, I'm letting it go
forward.
That way, he's going forward, but he's
falling backwards. Do you understand
that? And so, I don't ever feel his
weight. It's no different than goes
forward and then back. I'm just doing it
on his head. Okay. You do kash like this
and everyone comes this way. Okay. So,
don't hook.
Now, ask the question. Then, how do I
make him move that way? What do you
think it is?
>> Okay. And what's generating the adhesion
here?
>> His initial inertia.
>> His initial inertia. He's he's he's
pressing on that. I use that to move
him. You see that? Okay. All right. Try
a yong aspect. I keep that yong aspect.
This is what I when you hear me say I
equalize his yong aspect. Okay? So for
example,
if I go under value, there's no
adhesion. He didn't come that way. If I
go over value, I'm now contesting. But
if I match him, he gets stuck to me. Can
you see that? Can you feel feel
your skin go like that? Okay. Okay. So,
wait till you There we go.
Yeah. Okay. So, got it. So, he's
trapped. He can't go anywhere. And this
is what I meant this morning when I say
Iikido Kihon is using the inertia, the
centrial energy, the centrial energy to
generate what close-range grappling is
trying to do with fulcrums and leopards.
So now it's not that I'm trying to
leverage his head, his whole body. I
make the lever with the inertia going
forward.
Got it? And so watch my hand.
There's no tension in the arm. Okay. Try
it again.
Okay. So we're here and my drill is just
on the first step. So he goes to press.
What did I do wrong?
>> So behind me I went under yong value.
Go
over yong value.
Just this foot. I don't care what
happens. You can do it
with the other foot. Don't do this row.
Just bring it this way. Make sure his
center
passes.
It's not that I turn
cuz now the angle didn't change in his
posture. I don't turn.
Okay. Just this part. Try it.
>> What do you remember from the
energetics?
Does my hand what's on the other side of
the contestation have anything to do
with the integrity of the contact point?
>> Nothing at all. All that flexion is
unconscious tension in your body from
the from the pressure. Stay relaxed.
Move your own body. This is this what I
feel. So we go back to your quote. It
feels like nothing. This is supposed to
feel like nothing, too. This is what
this feels like. There's no one there.
My own weight and my hands are doing
exactly this thing.
We're just here.
[Music]
Okay. Feels like nothing. Well, now
we're just doing this.
Don't go till I get there. And he
gradually goes.
That's it. Okay. All right. Use the
energy, not his anatomy. Use the energy.
You understand the difference?
>> Okay. Uh, another thing, uh, we did
this. You guys mentioned stable base,
right?
He's pushing and we mentioned stable
base. Push, push, push, push. We
mentioned stable base. We come up,
>> right? Stable base. You see that the
energy goes down.
I have a stable. I move into stable.
I don't go from here.
Not stable base. Okay. I will move out
of the way so I don't trip him cuz I'm
not doing the throw. But I move the same
way.
Okay. Try to reduce the steps because
the more steps we need, the further we
are from the technique. Technique's two
steps. So
here
he's pressing
and okay. There's something else that
happens.
Um
and it's in those 10 off techniques.
There's balance is going in one
direction, right? As I tilt that spine
and when I crunch his spine anyway,
what happens to my line of gravity? So,
pay attention. I crunch it, it's moving
back under my basic support. Do you see
that? We have to keep the spine
extending on the initial
kizushi pattern. So when we do
we're here. Don't ask for me. He he goes
forward and I go like that and I crunch
that spine. His legs get back under him.
We go. I keep his spine long.
That's how I want you to do this throw.
You are going to feel there's no entry
line. You're going to feel this
that part. That part got heavy. Okay.
The kazushi is there as far as his spine
goes.
But that's heavy. You see? See how his
spine was going that way? It kept going
that way. But it got heavy. I want you
to feel the heaviness. Okay. Try it.
Just going to lengthen the spine.
Whoops.
Whoops. Okay. Go slower. Go slower.
Really slow.
There's no injury. I moved off.
Okay.
Okay. Got it. Okay. Try because you're
not moving into the in space. Okay. So,
when he goes here, we're going to have
to act it out. Okay. And I have his
center going forward and his body's
going back here.
His inertia was going forward and you
lengthen his spine. That's where the ump
comes from. You see what I'm going to do
instead is the center is going forward.
I go ahead and walk my friend. I'm
moving here.
The pressure on my arm does not change.
If I stay here, pressure increases on my
arm.
I move into the inspace.
Keeps the pressure the same on my arm.
I'm not throwing him. Yes, that's the X
pattern angle, but I'm not throwing him.
Okay. What I want you to do
is whatever it just felt like to me it
feels like two palms. Keep it two pound.
Okay.
So, I'm moving to keep that contact. I'm
not moving to make his head move. Okay.
All right. Try it. Can you tell me if
that is bending his back?
Okay.
That's the drill. Okay, try it again.
What I'm going to do is go around
everything. Come on, Sean.
You see? So, I'll leave this part out
and you'll see the fall still happens.
You see? So when this arm is going into
the inward spiral, which way do you
think he's going
>> down? Do you understand? It's not me
pushing him down. It's not me shoving
him down cuz he was going that way. I
turned his whole body and now I'm just
staying with it. I'm not pushing it
down. It's now going that way. And I'm
now blending it to keep his spine long.
Do you see that difference? So I'm not
going here
shoving this down. He already is falling
right there.
That move is not pushing on him. He's
going with him. Okay. So to get there, I
want you to understand
that first contact that you play, you go
here. Second one, don't shove. Move
around. So, what am I moving around?
Moving around that. And I'm moving
through this h space.
That's the technique.
Go right now. Okay. What would be wrong?
What would be wrong? He goes and I move
this.
I can't push it.
right here. Stay there. Keep this value.
Whatever that feels like to you, keep
it. Don't move into him. Move where
there's space.
Okay, that's the drill. Try it. Come do
that. Okay, watch something else. Okay,
that's where he is in he's going to be
there in the technique. Okay, so that's
my first impion point. He's pressing. I
use that. Where do he ends? Where does
he end up? Did you see? Pay attention.
Mark where he is on my arm. Don't look
at my feet. Look at where he is on my
arm. Over there.
You should feel it slide. Okay. Okay.
>> So, there's he's starting to press.
You see it? What happened?
I let it slip through. Okay. I'm not
increasing the value. If anything
decreased,